this podcast is brought to you by on it
go to audit.com and look at the great
selection of supplements if you find
something you like pressing code Joey
and get 10 off delivered right to your
house what's happening you bad
[__] the joint is brought to
you by
e listen I've been trying to eat healthy
for the past few years that's why I'm
taking beef organ supplements from heart
and soul beef organs are the most
nutrient dense then kale spinach and
blueberries combined that's why they're
called Nature's multivitamin let me tell
you something since I've been taking the
package of warrior supplements I'm
feeling Tip Top Magoo people ate organs
for thousands of years and never
suffered from obesity heart disease or
infertility because they were eating
organs Nature's Most treasured Foods
founded by Dr Paul saladino heart and
soul supplements are made from grass-fed
finished beef organs feel like a man
when you take supplements made from
liver heart kidney spleen and testicles
that's right I said testicles
[__] let the heart and soul help
you reclaim your brother your Birthright
the radical house go to heart and soul
that go and use Joey 10 for 10 off your
first daughter again that's heart and
soul dot Co CEO and use code Joey 10
offer applies to one-time purchases not
subscriptions take them today try them
today and see how you feel the recovery
is [__] tremendous and listen the
joint is also brought to you by manscape
make Santa envious with your own smooth
ball [__] sacked thanks to man's
Escape listen you gotta trim your bald
heads especially now especially during
the holiday season you don't want to go
on Santa's [__] Blacklist do you so
get the Platinum package it's got it all
it's a little more 4.0 the weed whacker
nose and head trimmer to protect your
delicate parts and holes and they're
waterproof so you can shave in the light
in the shower and it comes with a light
all of manscape shower gear is so
faith-free vegan and made to have your
skin feel hydrated and smelling fresh
you don't want to go into 2023 with a
[__] wolf man dick so right now get
20 off and free shipping with code Joey
at manscape.com again that's
manscape.com 20 off free shipping with
code Joey at manscape.com manscape get
your balls to Jingle for the holidays
let's get this party started [__]
it's Mondays I ain't got time to dilly
dally
hey how you doing good morning
check one two welcome to Uncle Joey's
Joy
[Music]
foreign
[__] it's Monday the 28th we
did it Thanksgiving is [__] over and
now we got the longest hurdle of the
[__] year
the six weeks of waiting not even six
[__] weeks we're at less than a
[__] month for Christmas guys so I
don't know what the [__] you thinking I
don't know what the [__] you're doing
it's Upon Us Jack was a great week last
week I had a great holiday uh
[__] Sunday last week I tested
positive for covid like I was telling
Mike you know I had [__] coven I had
had covered in June I had [__]
flu I pulled my [__] thigh muscle I
mean the hits didn't stop so when I
started feeling weird last I started
feeling it like Friday night
something wasn't right like I'd take
little [__] it was like having club
soda and you're like you know like what
the [__] and then Saturday
who the [__] knows then Sunday
we did the podcast we're sitting around
and my wife touched me and she goes
you're warm
and I go now it's the hot blood I don't
[__] know I I didn't feel good anyway
and we took the test I came up positive
and the first thing I think about was
[__] I gotta cancel Parks Casino and
I'm like that's the last thing I want to
do right now
especially if you're not [__] dying
Hey listen if you're dying from covid
you're on your stomach you're on
Facebook saying goodbye to your
relatives remember that [__] dying on
Facebook remember that the [__] with
nobody [__] released their Facebook
footage of grandma kicking the [__] they
should have just done a documentary I've
been waiting for the documentary of the
Facebook [__] debts but now if if I
was to that point I understand I got to
think about for years I've been thinking
around the people around me whenever we
talk about covet right because everybody
tells you you're going to get somebody's
grandfather sick or grandmother so
you're like okay
so you always try to be a good [__]
American and you're like you know I'll
stay home and my my business but after
72 hours you can't spread it no more if
I started to feel on [__] Friday or
Saturday
that means like by Monday Tuesday you're
good you know I'm no [__] Authority
on this thought she's dead and I don't
have a leg in this I thought she's
retired that's [__] crazy but all I
know is that uh I just held down I kept
drinking juice we didn't do a second
podcast I didn't want to get Mike sick I
didn't want to do anything else the only
thing I had on my mind was that [__]
set dirt Wednesday night at Parks Casino
that was it it was too late to go back
if I would have tested positive on
Tuesday
and felt shitty on Wednesday yeah
because then you got people in the green
room with you
you got people work at the casino but I
was like [__] it I'm just gonna sit here
to my ass girl's roots
I watched a couple movies I read half a
[__] book I've been dying to read
and it was Tip Top [__] Lagoon I'm
happy I did it because Sparks Casino let
me tell you something
Parx Casino
is definitely one of my favorite I like
I like the South Point see guys I don't
want to be jumping up and down I don't
need a pool with herpes in it at the end
with a thousand people in your bull
breeding on each other I don't need any
I don't need to see DJ fire I don't need
to see any of that [__] and I've never
had all those hotels when I go to Vegas
with Joe Rogan for [__] the UFC and
[__] we always got those off-color
hotels nobody knows nothing I wanna I
wanna smell death I want old people
around me I don't want to hear [__]
Vegas stupidity so I'm not into those
hotels
so when I think of a hotel like a casino
oh my God the [__] South Point
7 30 show you're in your room by nine
we're at the [__] Seafood Bar eating
[__] open turkey sandwiches with
mashed potatoes and shrimp cocktails I
almost choked on the [__] shrimp at
the South Point if it wasn't for my
brother John salami we wouldn't be here
right now he inflicted the [__]
Hamlet maneuver with a [__] our real
naked choke combination the [__]
shrimp went flying out of me so I love
Southpoint I love
Harris and San Diego holy [__] that's a
nice Casino
but I gotta tell you something man I
[__] love hanging out at Parks Casino
that's my third time there
it's beautiful it's easy
I met Lee at the hotel
this [__] went all over
Philadelphia and got food with an Uber
pizzas and [__] cookies and cannolis
and lobster tails I mean the guy was on
[__] fire he ate a 200 milligram
edible on stage ABX has been a long time
he was high till Friday
he ate it Wednesday night and he was
high till Friday he thought he was going
to sleep the eight hours in the train
back to Boston he went kaputs he was
wide awake let me tell you something
those ABX Edibles with the [__]
oxygen in them they will take you for a
[__] ride still every time you think
you got it like I'm Victor on that I'm
like you know what I think Thanksgiving
I popped five of them because I had
eaten four like a week ago holy [__]
I ate five of those ABX Edibles on
Thanksgiving I didn't do much on
Thanksgiving either at covet so
everybody knew it I didn't I couldn't go
anywhere you know everybody brings their
grandparents over whatever
so my neighbors were like listen
everybody that's coming over here had
covert last month everybody I don't know
why like six people over there
so I went over there to Puma's house it
was a [__] great Thanksgiving they
made a smoked turkey
and a regular turkey
good googly moogly the smoke that's the
first time I had it I was dying to have
a give me a couple slices so I could
melt like some [__] Italian bread
with some gouda cheese a nice turkey
something different you know what I'm
saying I didn't even make a turkey
sandwich I just had turkey again today
it was [__] delicious little white
meat turkey with some stove top stuffing
and [__] AKA prison days a little mashed
potatoes some cranberry sauce
you're off and running Jack
huh I don't know if cranberry sauce was
expensive or not I love that [__] I
could eat that [__] by the tub but after
the Pumas I came over I took a
tremendous turkey [__] and then I
inhaled a thousand milligrams of abx's
I did two or three bunk hits of [__]
uh I did a couple bungets of this new
rs2 from laughing gas
and by the time the bong hit juice wore
off the Edibles kicked in
and I gotta tell you something guys it
was the best [__] Thanksgiving
ever ever it was nice it was quiet the
whole [__] two days was nice Parks
Casino my set Parks Casino
was possibly
the best set I've had since I got back
into comedy I don't know what it was
I started looking at my notebook like uh
three weeks beforehand
just every day making little adjustments
there was a couple new things
there was a couple old things I revamped
and I just put them together
and everybody had a great time Eleanor
came up
Jimmy came up Lee came up Lee did the
200 milligram edible
we got some food down there
you know something light and I was home
it's a 42 minute drive
the [__] Parks Casino from here
holy [__]
everybody kept calling me going you
better leave for Parks early there's
going to be massive uh traffic oh my God
two million people will be driving to
destinations this weekend well
I didn't see none of those [__]
because it took me an hour for it to get
down there that is
I I don't I don't even understand it I
went down to nine I hooked the right on
the 33. it took me to the Jersey
Turnpike I swear to God I was in the
Jersey Turnpike 20 minutes and like all
right welcome to Philadelphia I'm like
welcome to Philadelphia all right and
next thing you know I saw it's time for
parts Casino I'm like come on
I caught my I looked at yeah I looked at
the thing of the wave and it said
20 minutes you're gonna be there in 20
[__] minutes like 2 42 it was 220 I'm
like okay then I saw Fox Casino sign I'm
like that's [__] easy I called my
wife I go I'm already here she's like
are you [__] crazy guys listen and I
read somewhere that I don't know if I
read oh I was at the gym on the bike
Friday
was yes Saturday Saturday I was the gym
at the bike and they showed a video of
some [__] people getting stabbed and
they see that [__] hard rock I think
[__] three people got stabbed
Thanksgiving tonight three people either
Thanksgiving night or Wednesday night
so I'm like you know what we went to
[__] parks
which is supposed to be Philadelphia and
it's supposed to be [__] you know
Murder Incorporated people gonna be
yelling at you they were as gentlemanly
as they could [__] be they were a
well [__] behaved audience everybody
I saw in the hallways was [__] great
Joey what's up Uncle Joey Happy
Thanksgiving
it was [__] no drama it was
tremendous the food I
guys I can't tell you this [__] Lee
brought into the Green Room this
[__] brought three Pies Two
tomato pies from Hannah iannesis [__]
great guy he gave me another sweatshirt
he brought two pies a ricotta pie a
tomato pie which I don't like a [__]
pie with no cheese on it but you gotta
taste these [__] pies
and uh he had lobster tails back there
it was great to see Eleanor the the
[__] the whole bang up of the night
was there was interpreters there
because there was a deaf dude in the
audience one deaf dude three interpret
is tremendous
so we get there and I don't want to be
addicted like you could either sit with
the interpreters you could sit in your
own room I'm gonna go no let's say with
The Interpreter so they hear my Patois
they you know they can hear what the
[__] I got to say I I taught it think
about it when was the last time I did
comedy with a [__] interpreter in the
stage and I was like
I don't know that's going to be rough I
was like this might be rough I was like
Doug I asked the career I'm like what
are you guys doing I'm like man I got
you guys want to smoke a number and
they're like we thought you'd never ask
so here we are five to eight outside
smoking a number with the three
interpreters [__] uh leaves out there
we're giggling
that it was [__] beautiful weather
you know for November [__] 23rd it
was [__] tremendous
and that was it the show went [__]
smooth
I want to thank everybody at [__]
parks
and that was it we got two more shows
left in the city
and then we decide what the [__] we're
gonna do but I gotta tell you man I came
home like I was telling you Thanksgiving
was kind of quiet before this hold on
one second and now for a word for my
[__] sponsor the episode of The
Joint is sponsored by Better Health
listen if life came with a user manual
things would be easy for everybody but
it doesn't so when it's not working for
you it's normal to feel a little bit
stuck navigating the career change a new
relationship or becoming a parent can
make you feel very uncertain therapists
are trained to help you learn productive
coping skills which makes therapy the
closest thing you'll get to a user
manual for you listen I love better help
it's online therapy that offers video
phone and chat therapy session I was
with Dana for a year about 14 months and
I tell you what it helped me amazing I
had never gone through therapy and this
was just what the doctor ordered let me
tell you something you can choose to see
someone on camera or not to but better
help is the world's largest therapy
service better help has matched three
million people with professionally
licensed and vetted therapists available
100 online plus it's a more affordable
just fill out a brief questionnaire to
match you with a therapist if things
aren't clicking you can see it a switch
to a new therapist anytime and I'll tell
you what it'll be quick
[Music]
be simpler no waiting rooms no traffic
no endless searching for the right
therapist learn more and save ten
percent off your first month at
betterhelp.com
Diaz again that's betterhelp.com
slash Diaz and now back to the show
we're back [__] I wanted to
before I got into this I wanted to talk
to you guys about it but out don't
forget to go to betterhelp.com
and uh just take a look that's all I ask
take a look the holidays are coming you
don't want to go into the holidays with
[__] baggage so you might as well
talk the better out talk to a licensed
professional anyway
sorry about the [__] covet call from
draining right now but
think about uh the Edibles on
Thanksgiving was I had like a you know
guys I
I think my favorite [__] part of life
and I tell you this with all enthusiasm
my favorite part of life
is the ability we have to always learn
right we have an ability to learn about
life
you can learn how to put a light bulb in
you can learn how to play the guitar you
can learn how to paint a picture at any
[__] age
but I think the mo the the best thing
about your life is
you get to know yourself
you get to learn something about
yourself nothing
[__] gets me riled up more
than you get like a moment and you go
wow what the [__] have I been for 60
[__] years
have I been in the goddamn closet I mean
how did I not see this and we all do
this and you're going to do this from
the age of 20 to the time you're [__]
90. you're gonna learn something new
about yourself an emotion
the reason why you eat the reason why
you don't eat you know you just learn
little things some of it is disturbing
and some of it is just a part of growing
up you know I found out a lot of things
about myself that were very [__]
disturbing and you put them into
perspective one way or another you know
when Mr Blue told me that [__]
If he if he had something that I wanted
that he would just give it to me because
I take it that [__]
crushed my soul when I was 26 years old
that I was just going to end up a
[__] miserable Thief after I thought
about and I talked to him and he's like
no you didn't understand what I said if
I if there's something that you want you
could [__] do it
that's what I was saying to you and I
was like okay but still it bothered me
it was something that I discovered about
myself that was life-changing like
you're like holy [__] I learned
something that important about myself
but
thank him tonight we came back and I
think we watched I don't know we watched
something some Garden of the Galaxy or
some [__] that was on and now they got a
new one on Disney I don't [__] know
and uh
my wife went upstairs Mercy went
upstairs and I was downstairs just
sometimes I just draw on the news and uh
I [__] just bent on a piece of paper
right
that's what that paper's for they cut
trees every day for it meanwhile you got
10 notebooks you don't write [__] in
them so I try to [__] Journal as much
as I can until the end I and I wasn't
journaling about anything in particular
maybe Thanksgiving how I felt what
happened at the fountain Parks Casino
nothing particular
and it [__] hit me you know I was
like wow you know
because we're so focused on what we
don't have
and trust me I'm the number I'll tell
you that I'm not focused
I'm what I don't have but I focus on
little things like that and it's
negative behavior you know I don't Focus
I don't go well I wish I had a
Testarossa or a Lamborghini no no that's
not what I mean I mean
you know I think about I wish I would
have gotten uh one of the two movies I
wish that would have worked out you know
you think about like uh
you know I wish I was a little younger
sometimes like I had five extra years to
run I wish I was 55 Maybe
to maybe go for it all over again you
know like go from theaters to bigger
venues I don't [__] know you know
but I tell you
we focus so much and this is part of
therapy this is part of everything one
thing I do wrong that I gotta stop but
I'll never do wrong is [__] on myself
you know in front of you guys I'll I'll
tell you my weaknesses or whatever and
at the end of the day they're really not
even weaknesses maybe you're having a
bad day or something but
can I was sitting here and I'm like wow
on Thanksgiving the Edibles that hit me
a little bit I'm hearing [__] I I
sometimes I hear the cat meowing
upstairs and I'm like what the [__] was
that you know I got my own issues guys
and uh we always think about like what
we have
or wealthy we don't get or what we don't
have you know
and again I don't sit here going I wish
I would have got that just sometimes you
get bummed out that man I wish I would
have got three days in that dinero movie
Man
I wish I would have got that Law and
Order episode man I wish you know
but uh at the end of that I was thinking
about how as a comedian
for the last 30 [__] years
I've looked at my accomplishments
I never really looked at the personal
accomplishments I always looked at
the accomplishments that had to do with
what I was doing for a job
see what I'm saying like like your
creative accomplishments like you know
if it was you if it was a regular
civilian like a nice civilian
you would be
focused on like your job your number one
in the sales area you've been number one
for four years you know before that you
were at a different place and you guys
were number one for 11 years you let the
sales team you really focus on that and
you really and then listen we all do
right like when you talk to people
what's going on with you beat uh I broke
the record this month I sold the most
toilet bowls yeah whatever the [__] you
know I sold the most cars I sold the
most scooters I don't know I don't know
I'm just saying you know but we always
rest our Laurels on that we all and I
guys you know Joey what's going on
nothing I became a feature act I'm doing
25 now instead of 20 you know nothing
else is going on with you now that's it
everything's good
okay you know I'm still doing coke you
know what's going on Joey I got a
girlfriend
and uh I'm still featuring now I'm
featuring a clubs you know you always
talk about that stuff right you have
another station you don't talk about
like
I got three [__] bees and an A okay
what are you excited about that for
because for the last three years I've
been a [__] idiot I've been living
off of [__] absent D's
so these personal accomplishments you
never really look at
because we're focused on like either
monetary accomplishments or career
accomplishments or creative
accomplishments and that's [__] great
but think about it like if Mike was in
the Foo Fighters
and Mike just wrote him out
right they just finished they just got
out of the studio the album is going to
get released December 21st
just to test you [__] because
you know
let's say Mike was going to have a kid
on the 15th
when I saw Mike on the 23rd what do you
think Mike would say to me first
he would tell me on the success of his
album
or that his child was born
you know what I'm saying like trust me
what I'm saying this to you like
you're not going to come up to me and
say hey
I just lifted you know I added 25 more
pounds on my bench press who would look
who would listen to you right people go
all right whatever hey guess what I just
got a stripe on my white belt people
will look at you and go hey who gives a
[__] hey you know I just got a stripe on
my [__] blue belt who cares but if
you go up to something right and I'm
mine we don't think anybody wants to
know about that [__] we just tell them
about
you could you could go to a [__]
physical and the doctor will sit you
down and go listen if I had five minutes
I call the Museum of Science and tell
them I got the perfect specimen
you just came in here your blood
pressure's perfect your PCA is perfect
your [__] diameter is perfect your
heart's perfect your lungs are perfect
you know everything's perfect I'm gonna
[__] call over there if you walked
out of there you still wouldn't say that
to me you would still say you know oh I
I [__] bartended the other night and
I made 1500 hours on a shift you
wouldn't even look at that as a [__]
accomplishment that with all these fat
[__] walking around and people with
diabetic feet going to Yankee games and
[__] and [__] with all this [__] you
wouldn't take that as a compliment
that's what I'm [__] talking about
that we don't I've never looked at like
you know what I have to [__] like
seriously like the other night I thought
about the 15 years I was all [__]
powder I haven't fought on the podcast
in a long time things are getting back
to normal [__] but I was
thinking about that like
I'm gonna take hard work that it wasn't
as hard as [__] me getting to be a
regular at the store
I don't know I don't remember but I tell
you it's worth something
and yeah Joey let's knock it off with
that you did Coke for 30 years you
didn't quit you just got tired that too
whatever it took and it's the truth you
get tired of running
no matter what I mean it's tough to be
50 and still chase a [__] bag every
day it's up to be 50 and go wow I'm
three dollars away from getting a 20
sack and I'm two more dollars from
buying a crack pipe I mean it's tough to
[__] say that unless things have
definitely not gone your way and you've
completely given up on yourself it's
really [__] hard to say that but that
night you know Thanksgiving night when I
[__] do all done
the thing I never wanted to do again
never mind comedy never mind
Coke never mind all this stupid [__] I
focus on I'm gonna tell you what I
didn't [__] focus on on Thursday
night
and it hit me like a bag of [__]
bricks how much of a long way I've come
my anniversary
that is the first time my anniversary
ever [__] dawned on me in my life
ever
ever 13 years of an anniversary toward
this woman who's [__] taken me from
[__] a a zero to a [__] [__] now
and you know
I mean it
especially where I came from
you know and I tell people this
constantly and I'll tell you guys man
either marriage works or it doesn't
you could make it work
or you can move the [__] on
I think that sometimes over the last 20
30 years I mean I've been separated
for 31 years now
and I think that a lot of us as
Americans gave up on our relationships
way
too [__] easy
when I got separated in 91 listen in my
heart
the marriage was done and I know it was
done it would have been horrible if we
would have stayed together it would have
been horrible horrible and guess what
people do for the sake of the kids or
the sake of convenience for the sake to
not to go through that we just become
very [__] you know [__] it we'll just
put up with it until somebody gets hit
by a truck or whatever the [__] you
expect to happen you know I mean you
know whatever and
I mean the marriage was over you know
she came to me three months later like
in December or January of
91 or some [__] 92 she came to me and
said hey
you're doing this I'm doing that let's
talk tomorrow and let's
try to get the relationship back I I
went out that night and got blasted
fell asleep at the girl I was Dayton's
house and
I don't know if she made it there that
day or not I just wrote it off as you
know it the universe watches back
together we'll get back together I was
young
I was very stupid and I uh never even
thought of calling her up and going hey
we should go talk to a priest hey we
should go do this
and then the the relationship just went
off the [__] deep end and now it's
over when that happened to me I I'll
never forget I made a [__] solemn
promise
because I didn't know I didn't know what
I had done I didn't know the
the levels that you [__] up when you
pull a marriage apart sometimes you
really don't know and for me I pulled it
apart and I threw you know I did what I
usually do I went out and started
drinking and smoking Coke
and I threw drugs on it and I never
really focused on what I needed to do
which sucked but hey we live and we
learn
but because I was such a [__] maggot
I said to myself well the blame wasn't
on me I'll never ever ever get married
again the blame was not on me I I made
some excuses how it just didn't work out
it was never going to work out how can I
be married if I was if I didn't have a
mother I I haven't
listened to anybody in 20 years tell me
what to do just stupid [__] you know
and uh from 90 it took 10 years to meet
the right woman you know it was right
for me and when I met my wife if you
like I could get around here one day to
tell you the brakes I put on
because I wanted to have a girlfriend
but I did not want to have a wife
and I did not want to even sell the
concept of wife I would have been very
happy
with [__] just having a girlfriend
why get married you fail at it why why
would I get married again it's like
[__] getting on a horse and the horse
bucks you and you [__] fly 30 feet in
the air and you break your [__] neck
well you're gonna get in the horse again
50 percent of people do but my fifty
percent won't I just won't it just
didn't work out for me whatever for
years is my relationship strengthened
with my wife that I I just [__] you
know said this is great this is great I
was a gentleman I tried my best not to
disrespect her
but marriage was never in my [__]
Gods it was it just was not gonna
[__] happen
and you know that was how I that was my
stand
in like 2002 2003 that this girl is
great
I could see me spending my life with her
hey I can't have kids B I don't want to
[__] another kid before it's right take
it away and see never mind kids I'm not
[__] getting married ever again
until 2008
after I took the blinders off from
cocaine and I saw what the [__] was at
stake
I thought about it I thought about it I
thought about it I went to see a friend
of mine we spoke about marriage
and that afternoon I just called my wife
and I go listen we're getting [__]
married because
I started thinking about her what worked
for me and what didn't work for me
didn't really matter anymore this girl
had put so much time into me
that I had a at least you know listen
what's that old expression I gotta I
gotta make a decent to whatever the [__]
people always but I got to make a decent
woman out of her and they're going to
make a decent man out of me it was time
for me to make a decent woman out of her
she had earned it
and against my own [__] beliefs
I was like you know typical Joey
how could I go get married I know she's
gonna get rid of me in five [__]
years but she realized what a loser I am
but I gotta be honest with you
it was the opposite effect
the the once I got married like my life
if you thought my life changed those two
years
without the drugs once I got [__]
married my life really took off because
it was like I was putting uh
not a responsibility yeah
yeah kind of like an extra
responsibility on me that I didn't have
when I was 20. I didn't look at the
responsibility I looked at it as a
[__] nuisance
you know when I was married when I was
20 she had her own account I had my own
account at the end of the month we'd
make a list of [__] bills and we'd
write a check to each other that's great
and people do it all the time and it
works for them
you know what for it to get into my
psyche that we were a team
I just said yeah put the bills together
for a long time I have an account as a
matter of fact today I have my own
account and she's got her own account
but we have a family account and we've
had that since
like three weeks after we got married
contrary to my selfish and
stupid beliefs it sets you up for the
mental of it we're a team
we're family we're a team what you're
going to take three dollars from me
that's what we're worried about that if
somebody's going to take our money right
you know how many people pulled me aside
and said you should get a prenuptial
why I got nothing
and if I do have something it's because
she made it possible
you know when we showed them we met
together we didn't have dick between the
both of us and when we got married we
didn't have dick we had a lot more than
what we had when we met and we had a lot
more than we had three years prior
because there was no more forty dollars
fifty dollars a day for cocaine so yeah
that little [__] psyche we did to put
our accounts together just to dip money
in there I would put my sag checks in my
account everything else would go into
the house account so those 15 three
dollar checks nobody wants those anyway
I would put those in my account and
without doing coke guess what they had
the [__] up so
it was perfect
but the I look at my wife Thursday at
Thanksgiving and I'm like never mind the
you know eight years and nine years we
were together
now I want to get a 13 years bonding my
marriage it's been a complete different
[__] experience
and
I was sitting there that night I know I
was high and I know that
you know whatever happened on
Thanksgiving you're floating on [__]
whatever
but still I didn't I never looked at
that accomplished meant I never looked
at it you know my friend told me that as
mother and father
have been together for 63 years
63 years that's longer than Batman and
Robin
That's longer than Batman and Robin you
know and
because of my age and whatever I'll
never be in my wife the 63 [__] years
but
you think about that that's a long time
to be with somebody
your souls are definitely [__]
connected if one of those guys dies the
other one will be dead within a month
maybe two maybe three months because
they can't breathe without one another
I'm not at that point my wife yet that's
not what I'm talking about
what I'm talking about is the little
things we don't look at
you know you're too busy oh I sold out
the Chicago Theater oh we sold out parks
but you know what my kid is healthy
a kid is healthy she's smart
she's goofy you know she's not living a
[__] life like I was living my wife
is happy she's got a little part-time
gigna
she's happy we Overlook those [__]
things all the time because we're
looking for the bigger payout like the
bigger payoff and you know what if
you're always looking for the bigger
payoff it's never gonna [__] come
focus on these little [__] payoffs
and when I made my payoffs I don't mean
nobody giving you money
I mean life's payoffs the universe gives
you [__] payoffs and trust me I was
the first guy I raised my hand I never
even saw those
[__] Universal payoffs because you're
too busy you're too busy with your
[__] head up your ass waiting for the
[__] uh you know the Readers Digest
[__] 1.2 million dollar Lotto check
when you don't win it you get
disappointed no [__] no
it's about the little things and I've
always said this for years that little
commitments
become [__] big commitments it
depends on how much time you got
you're gonna get there the success is
definitely going to come the odds are in
your favor but how much do you have are
you willing to [__] hang in there
who the [__] knows do you think I
[__] thought I would hang with comedy
for 10 years being broke and who the
[__] knows I had nothing else but I knew
that nothing happens in the couch and I
knew that the more I [__] showed up
there the more I [__] showed up there
every week I was getting [__] strong
it's like my man in Apocalypse Now says
you know I'm over here in a room
getting [__] weaker and Charlie's out
there in the bush getting [__]
stronger you know that that Hey listen
guys that's that's [__] as easy as
can be and it's [__] real
if you're not out there [__] grinding
for whatever you believe in for me it
was uh I wanted the marriage to work I
just want I did not want to be a double
divorce a guy I did not want to be
walking around talking about how my ex
is a [__] witch and it doesn't work
out and don't get married
so I try a little extra even with the
road and distractions and all the
[__] that comes with it I focused on
it and I never ever looked at
how good I felt about it how good I felt
that we're both together for my daughter
I mean there's some guys anything could
[__] happen at any given day my wife
could wake up and then go you know what
Joey I get sick and tired of sniffing
your [__] tongue guy fungi toenail
it's time to go back to Tennessee and
I'll accept it because I know I gave it
a [__] Yankee try [__] stuck it
out till the end you know I didn't just
quit when [__] you know you ever talked
to like your grandparents
what do you think they didn't have
[__] the issues people have today
they didn't have money problems and [__]
they just didn't quit their relationship
got [__] stronger
you know I read about all the divorces
during covert I don't know if we could
get the church tape on this
I said it like the [__] month after
the pandemic shot us down
I was sitting in my office scared you
know
doing something on Facebook I shouldn't
have been doing a Twitter or whatever
the [__] and I'm like my wife is out
there by herself
you know I got two choices during this
pandemic I could either weaken our
marriage
or I could sit back here like a jerk off
and leave
um social media and write stupid jokes
what are you writing jokes for you're
not going nowhere to crack them unless
you got a zoom show at eight [__]
o'clock you know which I didn't want to
[__] do a zoom show so
I said let me go sit next to my wife and
you know what we became stronger during
the pandemic I mean it was our
relationship instead of getting weaker I
mean listen when you're married like a
[__] you didn't tell you that this
days you wake up you want to stab your
wife in the eye with a pencil don't get
me wrong okay
Michael Tire anybody who's married will
tell you
there's some days you wake up and you're
like
but 100 of the time I love it to death
so
this taught me is after Thanksgiving
last week it was like a sort of a
[__] Thanksgiving remember like they
sold Thanksgiving in the beginning
you're supposed to sit with your family
and be thankful for all the good things
that happened this year
for me it was a realization that
[__] good things have been happening
all along I just never looked at them
and if I didn't look at them I'm sure a
lot of other people are living the same
life as I am you know you're focused on
the little things my girlfriend blew me
you know she put a firecracker up my
hand but you're not focusing on the [__]
I really did that work
like
I got a weird respect for [__]
doctors lawyers you know why because
it's a seven year education
seven [__] year education
what would be we bail at it
two years we're gonna [__] this
five more years of this [__] seven
[__] years
I admire that that's why now I wish I
didn't have the [__] families because
I would go back to school get because I
know it could be done and I tell people
this all the time you're not gonna you
know when I say to you listen you could
do this it's gonna take you four years
four years
come on man just
just do it put your head down wake up
smile
you know give a [__] uh whatever to
yourself for being alive giving you
another day to be alive and go to the
Grind again people are going to yell at
you people gonna call you a loser you're
doing this wrong Mike you didn't measure
it right you giggle because you know
in four years you won't even see this
[__] no more in four years
you're not even gonna talk to this fat
[__] anymore
you're gonna be out there running your
[__] game so
it's just so weird that the things we're
not thankful for we're not thankful for
we're thankful for the bigger things
they took a selfie with Queen Latifah
you know who gives a [__] if that's what
your [__] day is consistent of that's
what you're gonna get in your life is
that type of [__]
but if you're gonna go [__] today
I ran an extra [__] eight minutes
people don't look at that as an
accomplishment they're like you know and
they don't even mention it to nobody
don't rather go you know I I picked up
11 more Instagram friends you know no
you didn't look at the little things in
your life that's why you're not taking
you're not taking the right inventory of
your life listen guys I I love what I'm
doing now it's simple it's easy I did
the heavy lifting and now I'm here to
just
to a podcast twice so we can help you
guys out if I can do some [__] comedy
from time to time I [__] love it this
is the pace I wanted I'm not wasting
nobody's time anymore if you want in
your hand if you don't take a [__]
hike we're [__] six weeks away right
not even
we're [__] 32 days away from [__]
Christmas we did it again this is what
my 10th year celebrating Christmas on
the [__] internet and [__] like this
what but we're here this is the time of
the year that listen this is the time of
the year not to have a [__] stress
out you're not going to play catch-up
it's like when people want to lose
weight like I only lost three pounds
what are you 150 pounds overweight that
didn't take [__] three days so sit
relax put it in if you're behind the
eight ball this year already who gives a
[__] don't stress it because you're not
gonna play catch a ball right now
if you're not behind a [__] eight
ball and you had a fantastic year look
at you look at you [__]
just lay in these accomplishments and go
I [__] did it and guess what 2023 is
going to be better I feel optimistic
about 2023 I feel uh
the book is coming out it'll give me
some different options to explore
yeah I don't know what a [__] stand-up
comedy's going but I know I'm feeling
better than I ever have I'm getting old
I'm an old Billy Goat and I'm looking
forward to these [__] next couple
years so if you got anything from the
morning Monday Morning podcast today is
be excited about your [__]
accomplishments you're not looking at
career accomplishments you're looking at
personal accomplishments you know what
you lifted 10 more pounds on a bench
press tell everybody tell everybody
guess what what I lifted 10 more [__]
pounds on my bench press people looking
that's great for you [__] you I'm this
is how we celebrate the little [__]
things guys that we always Overlook and
then we go [__] haven't done anything
this year trust me you've done enough I
love you [__] with all my heart
don't forget
it's Monday [__] you need your
weed for the week
stonerclub.com Preston Uncle Joey and
we're going to give you a 10 [__]
discount listen those uh Edibles are
tremendous to 15 milligram ones don't
get [__] confused with those things
they got the punch Edibles they had some
[__] gelato some what did they have
that was really [__] some weed two
weeks ago a week ago I forget what the
[__] it was uh Gorilla Glue it's a
hybrid if you go to Stoner Club
and you see Gorilla Glue hybrid they
probably have it on sale now because
they've had it for two weeks [__] get
some of that [__] that should have put
you in a different dimension and that
said [__] suck because you got
stonerclub.com
code Uncle Joey 10 off and I think today
they still got 25 off on everything for
Black Friday so tell them Uncle Joey
sent you I love your [__] have a
great week stay black and I'll see you
another day this week we haven't decided
all right you bad [__] I want
to thank you don't forget love what
you're [__] doing right now every day
the joint is brought to you by better
help if life came with a user manual
things wouldn't be things would be easy
for everybody but it doesn't so when
it's life's not working for you it's
normal to feel a little stuck navigating
the career change a new relationship or
becoming a parent can make you feel
uncertain so I listen I'm with you
therapists are trained to help you learn
productive coping skills
better help is online therapy that
offers video phone and chat therapy
sessions you can choose not to see
anyone or you can see 20 people makes no
difference to me let me explain
something to you when you're stuck
better help is tremendous I was with
them for 14 months and Dana showed me
the light at the end of the double
as we're concerned the world's largest
therapy service better help has matched
3 million people up with professionally
licensed and better therapists available
100 online plus it's affordable just
fill out the brief questionnaire to
match you with a therapist if things
aren't clicking and you can easily
switch to a new therapist anytime it
couldn't be simpler no waiting rooms no
traffic learn more and save 10 off your
first month at betterhelp.com Diaz again
that's betterhelp.com Diaz the joint is
also brought to you by heart and soul
beef organ supplements beef organs are
more more nutrient dense than kale
spinach blueberries combined that's why
they're called Nature's multivitamin
listen I've been feeling great my
recovery is tremendous my farts are
Sensational people wait organs for
thousands of years never suffer from OB
easily heart disease or infertility
because they were eating organs founded
by Dr Paul saladino heart and soul
supplements are made from grass-fed
finished beef organs feel like a man
when you take supplements made from
liver heart kidney spleen and [__]
testicles you Savages let heart and soul
help you reclaim your Birthright the
radical Health go to heart and souls.go
and use code Joey 10 for 10 off your
first daughter that's heart and soul
taco and use code Joey 10 off replies to
one-time purchases not prescriptions the
joint is also brought to you by manscape
listen you can make Santa jealous when
he sees your nutsacked it's going to be
nice trim and smooth how did you get
them manscape.com the Platinum Four
package 4.0 package has it all the
lawnmower 4.0 body trimmer the weed
whacker nose and ear hair trimmer
protect your delicate parts and holes
and they're waterproof so you can shave
in the shower nicely moves and they got
a light so even if the [__] power
goes off you can shave that [__] all
the manscape shower gear is sulfate free
vegan and made to have your skin feeling
hydrated and smelling fresh
today I'm going to get you 20 off in
free shipping with code Joey j-o-e-y at
manscape.com again that's code Joey
at manscape.com that 20 off and free
shipping with the code Joey at
manscape.com I want to thank manscape I
want to thank Better Health and I want
to thank heart and soul but most
importantly I want to thank you guys
thank you very much for having my back
and I'll see you guys again later this
week stay black Uncle Joey loves you
[__]
foreign
[Music]